the world is changing super fast in
television
but televisions haven't kept up
so sky glass is incredible innovation
it's all the technology that comcast and
sky have been working on for over a
decade
and it comes to life all the wires are
going all the boxes are gone
you can talk to it it tells you
what you want to see it shows it to you
right away you can switch from music to
exercise to television
to news it's an amazing product and i
give great credit to the team here at
sky for their innovation
is this an offensive move or a defensive
move
i think it's
offensive because sky has been a leader
for long before comcast was lucky enough
to be involved
in changing what television is all about
and obviously with streaming and the
internet you don't need a satellite dish
the ability to have two-way
communications
and to eventually change the actual
viewing experience using
all sorts of new technologies that come
along from the cloud
so you want to be connected to that
cloud but you want to do it simply and
have a company you trust bring it to you
and that's what sky can do this is of
course taking sky into a new front
against businesses like lg and samsung
with which it's never competed in the
past
yeah i look less about trying to
displace
those companies
and more bring together what sky can do
and
we're going to be able to license our
technology all over the world we're
pleased to have
foxtel joining on this launch date and
so it's a journey we're on but it's more
than just the actual physical television
in fact that's
what's so great about the product is the
physical
television is the maybe the smartest in
the world
but it's what's behind it that that
makes that claim so true and that we can
do with others over time as well
now elsewhere in the media universe and
telecoms universe at t has just spun off
its entertainment on warner media you
appear to be going in the opposite
direction and more deeply integrating
distribution and entertainment
i think um you know each company has a
different strategy so i i can't speak to
them but they're
our dna
my dad founded comcast was about making
television better back in tupelo
mississippi in 1963
and that's what we have been doing from
two or three channels of television
to what you get today with literally
infinite choices
att started in a different place and so
the the culture and the fit it can be
different in different companies so for
us we're having a record year even
despite
all the headwinds of covid and pubs and
clubs
being shut for part of the year sport
being suspended
today we've resumed we have all the sky
customers are back more than ever
globally our company i think will have
our best year in history
and there's real momentum so it's
working you can't be sure about the
future but we are trying real hard with
innovation and new products and that's
what today's announcement's all about
what are your observations on how the
wider comcast group how it traded
through the pandemic i mean obviously
life was very difficult for the
universal parks and resorts for example
that's a great question and that's
that's what
was our biggest 70 75 percent of our
problem was one business theme parks
what gave me great confidence
was
how much pinup demand there is to have
fun and
get back and enjoy life
and i'm here visiting this week i am
experiencing that in london which is
very different than parts of the united
states right now
and that's what's happened with theme
parks as they've opened safely and
thoughtfully around the world
they're more
demand
than there was even before the pandemic
and that's without a lot of
international travel
now one very significant development
during the pandemic was that you
released trolls world tour and that went
straight to streaming rather than a
cinematic release
does that spell the death now for
traditional cinema operators i
definitely hope not and don't believe it
has in fact this week james bond or last
week james bond world premiere was here
in london the results looked stellar
over the weekend for movie theaters
again there's something magical my wife
and i would go to the movies
each week for the last 30 plus years
it's it's what film can be in its
greatest form
that said as a new generation comes
along as great devices like
sky glass come to your home with the
home sound and theater capability
giving consumers options and choices a
night out
you know date night
or stay home and be with the family or
some of both
and having the capability for those
films to appear in new windows is what
we want to experiment with cover force
that conversation but i don't believe by
any means that theaters won't be a big
part of our future
now another big recent development is
that you've just entered a joint venture
with viacom cbs sky showtime being
rolled out across 20 european countries
are there more tie ups like that in the
pipeline i think a lot of companies
look at and have always partnered with
other companies
while they're doing their own thing and
so in the case of sky showtime we
clearly are very happy here in the uk
and ireland
and germany and italy sky's core markets
but there's a larger europe
and if you add up all of viacom cbs
showtime nbc
universal
and sky
that's a lot of great content and in
this new
form to go to markets where we
heretofore have not been core
we want to go there in a streaming mode
maybe someday using sky glass as a as a
vehicle
it made a lot of sense to tie up with
each other and try something like this
now we're approaching the third
anniversary of comcast winning the
takeover battle for sky
what's surprised you about the sky
business the most since you actually got
your hands on the business
well we
are thrilled that we made the deal
brexit happened
and there was a lot of uncertainty
and
during that period and then of course
covet happened and it disrupted skye's
business as usual
what i'm most surprised is how resilient
and how
the the brand of sky and the ingenuity
of the management and the company's
operations allowed sky to thrive sky
news
trusted maybe the most trusted source of
news during this important period for
people to figure out what was happening
with covid
and and other world events
so no surprise
but a pleasant
reassurance that skye's business is
solid and was ripe for the next chapter
and so about three years ago
we had a management off site
and the team from sky said we want to
show you something we're working on i
love to see new products and and they
showed us glass
in a very rough form and we moved some
folks from comcast
onto the glass team we have plenty of
sky people helping with
other projects like peacock in the
states for nbc and that collaboration
brings us to today
and the product
is i believe the best in the world
and that is what sky is known for it's
what attracted us to sky
and i'm so pleased we are together